hi everyone
this is professor m.science and today i
want to talk about
minimum uncertainty states in another
one of our videos on rigorous quantum
mechanics
you'll all have heard about the position
momentum heisenberg uncertainty
principle
it tells us that the product of the
uncertainty in x
and the uncertainty in p has a lower
bound the question we ask today
is pretty simple for which states do we
actually have the minimum possible value
for this product
these states that minimize the
uncertainty are called
minimum uncertainty states and today
we'll see that they actually take
a very familiar form let's go we start
with a quick refresher on the
uncertainty principle
the first ingredient we need is the
state of the system psi
we then also consider two observables a
and b the expectation value of
observable a
in state psi is written like this and is
given by psi
a psi remember that the expectation
value gives the average of the
distribution of the eigenvalues
associated with the eigenstates that
contribute to the expansion of the state
in the a basis in a similar way the
expectation value of observable b
in the same state psi is given by the
analogous expression
the next quantity we need is the root
mean square deviation which we write as
delta
a and is equal to the square root of the
expectation value of sigma a
squared where sigma a is measuring the
distance of observable
a from its mean what this means is that
the root mean square deviation is a
measure of the width of the distribution
of the eigenstates of a
that make up the state psi
we can also rewrite the root mean square
deviation as equal to this expression
for observable b we have an analogous
expression for the root mean square
deviation
where again sigma b is defined as the
distance from the corresponding min
and delta b can also be written like
this
ok these mathematical definitions and
their meaning should be familiar to you
but if you need a more in-depth
refresher then you can check out our
video on expectation values linked in
the description
we now come to the uncertainty principle
it says that delta
a multiplied by delta b is larger than
or equal to one half times the absolute
value of the expectation value of the
commutator
between a and b what does this mean
when we write the state psi in the two
bases of eigenstates of
a or b then the widths delta a
and delta b associated with the two
expansions are related by this equation
in particular if a and b do not commute
then it is impossible to simultaneously
make these two distributions arbitrarily
narrow
and again we explore these ideas in much
more detail in the videos on the
heisenberg uncertainty principle
where we both derive the mathematical
proof of this result and go into its
conceptual
meaning
what we'll do today is to focus on a
specific example of the uncertainty
principle
the one for which the operators are
position and momentum
position and momentum operators do not
commute in quantum mechanics
and their commutator is equal to i h bar
using this general expression up here we
can rewrite the uncertainty principle
as delta x delta p larger than or equal
to h bar over 2.
with this today's video is pretty
straightforward we'll ask the question
of under what conditions this relation
becomes an or put another way
what states of the system lead to the
product of delta x
delta p taking its minimum value h bar
over 2.
the resulting states are called minimum
uncertainty states
and they appear in a variety of contexts
with an important example being that of
coherent quantum states so i encourage
you to check out the corresponding
videos
to find out what these minimum
uncertainty states are we'll first
rederive the uncertainty principle for
the special case of position and
momentum operators
now you may wonder why i would want to
do this given that we already proved the
most general form of the uncertainty
principle in another video
well it turns out that the alternative
derivation that we'll discuss today
provides a very clear path to determine
minimum uncertainty states
so that's why we'll rederive it let's
assume our system is in the state
psi we next build the new state phi
equal to sigma x plus i lambda sigma p
all acting on psi and we choose lambda
to be real
just to be absolutely clear sigma x and
sigma p
are calculated with respect to the state
psi of our system
the next step is to use the positivity
property of the scalar product which
implies that the norm of phi
is positive or zero recalculating the
norm of phi
we can plug in its definition in terms
of psi to first get the bra
and then the cat remember that to build
the brain dual space
we need this minus sign here because all
scalars turn into their complex
conjugates
and in principle we would also need the
adjoints of all operators but sigma x
and sigma p are hermitian because x and
p are hermitian
and so we don't need the adjoints
multiplying through we get a term
proportional to sigma x
squared then the cross term proportional
to the product of sigma x
sigma p and to sigma p sigma x
and finally a term proportional to sigma
p squared
this here is the commutator of sigma x
and sigma p
it is actually very easy to evaluate
this commutator
we can insert the definitions of sigma x
and sigma p
the scalar terms here and here commute
so we end up with a canonical
commutation relation between position
and momentum
which is equal to i h bar this means
that this term up here
is i h-bar combining i
lambda with i h bar gives minus lambda h
bar as a result we can rewrite the
scalar product of phi with itself
as equal to the expectation value of
sigma x squared
minus lambda h bar plus lambda squared
times the expectation value of sigma p
squared and due to the positivity of the
scalar product up here
this whole expression needs to be larger
than or equal to zero
let's make sure that this expression is
absolutely clear the state of the system
is psi
and all these expectation values are
calculated with respect to this state
psi
as indicated by the sub-indices here and
here
the state phi here or here
is simply a mathematically convenient
state that we exploit
to reach inequalities such as this one
that we've just derived
overall we've ended up with a general
quadratic inequality in lambda
so in the next slide we'll take a break
from quantum mechanics and go over a
quick refresher about some important
properties of quadratic functions that
we'll need
consider a general quadratic function f
of lambda
equal to a lambda squared plus b lambda
plus c we want to consider the general
problem of a function
f of lambda that is larger than or equal
to 0 for
any lambda what this means is that
every possible set of values for a b
and c define a particular quadratic
function f
and we're looking for all possible
values for which the resulting quadratic
function
is larger than or equal to 0 for any
value of lambda
the very first thing that we can say is
that a needs to be positive
if a were negative then whatever the
choice of b
or c the function would tend to minus
infinity
for large enough lambda so the condition
that this function needs to be
non-negative
cannot be fulfilled with a negative a
to explore what other conditions we have
on the form of the quadratic function
let's draw a pair of axes with lambda on
the horizontal axis
and f of lambda in the vertical axis
we have three possible situations the
first is this one
where the quadratic function takes both
positive and negative values depending
on lambda
this is the second situation where the
quadratic function only takes positive
or zero values but has no negative
values
and it is the third situation where the
quadratic function
only takes positive values the functions
in the diagrams have a positive
curvature because we've already
determined that a
must be positive from these diagrams we
can see very clearly which cases will
fulfill the condition up here
both this case and this case are such
that
the function does not take negative
values but this first diagram does not
work
because the function does become
negative for some values of lambda
in particular this range here
so how can we make this argument more
quantitative
essentially we can see that the number
of times the function f
crosses the lambda axis determines
whether it goes negative or not
conveniently we know how to figure out
how many times a function crosses the
horizontal axis every crossing point
corresponds to a real root of the
quadratic function
f of lambda equal to zero
the general solution to such a quadratic
equation is given by this standard
formula that you learned in high school
the key quantity we're interested in to
determine how many real roots we have
is the argument of the square root here
and we're going to label it with a
capital delta
and it is called the discriminant
i am using a capital delta to denote the
discriminant because it is the usual
notation
but don't confuse it with the capital
delta that appears when we write the
root mean square deviation
the latter is always followed by an
operator
let's go back to the diagram and start
with the first case where the function
crosses the lambda axis
here and here and it goes negative in
between
in this case the quadratic equation has
two real solutions which corresponds to
discriminant larger than zero
so the argument of the square root is
positive
in the second case the function stays
positive and goes to zero
at a single point here which is also the
minimum value that the function takes
this means that the quadratic equation
has a single real solution
which corresponds to the discriminant
being equal to zero
in the third case the function does not
cross the lambda axis
so there are no real roots which happens
when the discriminant is negative
for our inequality up here we want the
function to never take negative values
this means that we need either this
situation or
this situation and this implies that the
discriminant
must be smaller than or equal to zero
right this is it for our summary of
quadratic inequalities
and we're now ready to go back to
quantum mechanics
remember from our discussion a moment
ago that positivity of the scalar
product
of phi with itself implies that we have
this inequality
in the general language of quadratic
functions this term
is a this term is b
and this term is c the discriminant
becomes h bar squared minus 4 times the
product of the two expectation values
and from our discussion of general
quadratic functions summarized up here
we know that the inequality will hold if
the discriminant is smaller than or
equal to zero
we therefore need the same for our
discriminant
rearranging this implies that the
expectation value of sigma x squared
times the expectation value of sigma p
squared is larger than or equal to h bar
squared over four
remembering from the first slide that
the root mean square deviation of an
operator a
is equal to the square root of the
expectation value of sigma a squared
then we can take the square root of this
expression and we end up with delta
x delta p larger than or equal to h bar
over 2.
and this is it we've rederived the
heisenberg concerning the principle for
the special case of position
and momentum again as we said earlier
there is a more general derivation for
arbitrary operators that we briefly
discussed in the first
slide and that you can find link in the
description but this derivation for the
special case of positional momentum will
prove
very useful to determine minimum
uncertainty states
so how can we find these minimum
uncertainty states
let's recall what we've done starting
with the positivity of the scalar
product of phi with itself
we found that it implies that we have
this inequality
and in turn we just derived that this
inequality leads to the uncertainty
principle
again remember that phi here is not the
physical state of the system it is an
intermediate state that we exploit for
the mathematical derivations
the state of the system is psi and this
is the state with respect to which
expectation values are calculated
here and here we can now see that the
case for which the scalar product
vanishes
will lead to this equality
which in turn will lead to the minimum
uncertainty condition
so all we have to do to determine the
minimum uncertainty states is to enforce
that this starting equation
has an equal sign if we copy again the
scalar product of phi with itself
being equal to zero then the positivity
of the scalar product
implies that phi itself must vanish
remembering the definition of phi as
equal to the sum of these two operators
acting on psi we can then conclude that
the minimum uncertainty state psi
must obey this equation
to make progress we'll rewrite this
equation in slightly different way
we need to remember that the operator
sigma of an arbitrary operator
a is defined as measuring the distance
with respect to the expectation value
using this expression for sigma x and
sigma p
we end up with this equation for the
minimum uncertainty state
and this is it all we have left to do is
to determine the state psi database this
equation
and such a state will be the state that
minimizes the uncertainty principle
we'll do this working in the position
representation in terms of wave
functions
and we'll actually find that the wave
functions associated with minimum
uncertainty states
actually look rather familiar
the minimum uncertainty state is given
by the state psi
database this equation the first step is
to write it down in the position
representation
we start with the position operator
which simply acts as a multiplicative
factor
in the position representation we then
have this scalar
which we simply copy and we then have
this term proportional to the momentum
operator
and it acts as a differential operator
in the position representation
and then we have a term proportional to
the scalar which again we copy
all of this is acting on the state psi
which becomes the wave function
psi of x in the position representation
and
all is equal to zero if you need a
refresher about how we transform states
and operators into the position
representation then you can find
our videos on wavefunctions and
positional momentum operators linked in
the description
but overall we now have a differential
equation for the wavefunction
psi of a minimum uncertainty state
so far all steps have been rather
straightforward but now is when the
magic happens
we're going to apply a change of
variables that does not look intuitive
at all
but as we'll see it will make our lives
much easier moving forward
we set the wave function as equal to the
exponential
of i times the expectation value of p
times
x divided by h bar all multiplied by a
function u
of x minus the expectation value of x
to see how our equation transforms under
this change of variables
let's start by calculating the
derivative of psi
inserting this expression for psi in
here
we can then use the chain rule and we
get the derivative of the exponential
times the function u plus the
exponential
times the derivative of u
we can take the exponential as a common
factor
and then get the term proportional to
the expectation value of momentum
plus the term involving the derivative
all acting on u
using this change of variables we can
now rewrite the full equation up here
we start with the exponential which is a
common factor
we then have the position terms up here
which we can simply copy
this scale of factors combined to lambda
h-bar
which we can copy and for the derivative
we use this expression we just derived
and we get the term proportional to the
expectation value of momentum
plus the derivative and finally we have
this term
which we simply copy all of this acts on
the function u
and all is equal to zero
we can now cancel this term with this
term
and we can also remove the overall
exponential because we're equating to
zero
this means that we end up with the term
proportional to position
the derivative term
all acting on u and all equal to zero
to write the derivative term i've used
the fact that the
x minus the expectation value of x is
equal to the
x and it is true because the expectation
value here is a scalar
we finally end up with this new much
simpler
differential equation what i have
defined q
as equal to x minus the expectation
value of position
this differential equation is now very
easy to solve we can use separation of
variables
and write the u dependent terms on one
side
and the q dependent terms on the other
we can then integrate both sides with
respect to q
the left hand side gives the logarithm
of u
and the right hand side gives the term
proportional to q squared
plus an integration constant
exponentiating we get that
u is equal to a times the exponential of
minus q
squared over 2 lambda h bar
where the constant a is the exponential
of the original integration constant
remembering the relation between psi and
u
and the relation between q and x
we can now use the solution for u up
here to write psi of x
as equal to a then we have the
exponential here
which stays the same and then we have
the exponential from here
which becomes this if we use the
definition of q in terms of
x
the next step is to determine the
normalization constant a
to do so we insist that the wave
function is normalized by integrating
over all
space writing out the explicit
expression for the wave function
we get the absolute value squared of a
multiplied by the integral of the square
of the second exponential
the first exponential in the wave
function here is a face
so it cancels with this complex
conjugate in the absolute value
at this point we can use a standard
gaussian integral
which is equal to this to rewrite our
integral
as the absolute value squared of the
normalization constant
times the square root of pi lambda h bar
gaussian integrals like this one are
very useful and we use them often
and you can find them tabulated in many
places including wikipedia
finally we can isolate the absolute
value squared of a
to be equal to this and in turn this
implies that a
is equal to this where i have made the
face
choice such that a is real and positive
and this is it the wave function of a
minimum uncertainty state
is equal to this pre-factor this phase
factor
and this exponential
we can also calculate the absolute value
squared of the wave function
which is equal to this pre-factor times
this exponential
but this is not just any exponential
it's a gaussian
and this is the big conclusion today
minimum uncertainty states have
gaussian wave functions and
if you've been following our other
videos you'll now realize that we've
already encountered minimum uncertainty
states before
without necessarily being aware of it
we've encountered gaussian wave
functions as the ground state of the
quantum harmonic oscillator
and also as coherent states all of these
are minimum uncertainty states
now while this gaussian form is the key
message today we can actually take a
final step to determine this constant
term lambda here
and here and this is what we'll do to
finish the video
let's go back to our slide with the
general discussion of quadratic
inequalities
we now know that minimum uncertainty
states correspond to the special case
when this inequality up here
takes its minimum value which
corresponds to having an equality
from the diagrams we see that this only
happens in the middle case
and for this specific value of lambda
which i'll call lambda 0.
this means that for minimum uncertainty
states
we need the precise value of lambda that
corresponds to the crossing point with
the lambda
axis put another way we'll need lambda 0
equal to the single root minus b over 2a
remember that this is the form of our
quadratic inequality
and comparing this expression with the
general quadratic function up here we
see that
this is a this is b
and this is c this means that in our
case
lambda 0 is equal to h bar over 2
times the expectation value of sigma p
squared
and remembering that the expectation
value of sigma p squared is simply the
square
of the root mean square deviation we can
rewrite our latest expression
in terms of delta p finally using the
fact that the minimum
uncertainty states obey this relation by
definition
we can also write lambda 0 in terms of
delta x
and now we have all ingredients to fully
specify the minimum uncertainty states
we can simply insert this expression for
lambda 0
in here and in here and doing so we get
that the wave function
of a minimum uncertainty state is equal
to this pre-factor
times this exponential times this
gaussian exponential
the corresponding absolute value squared
is equal to this pre-factor times this
gaussian exponential
we'll leave it here today but remember
that you can find examples of these
minimum uncertainty states
in the videos linked in the description
the quantum states that minimize the
uncertainty principle have a gaussian
shape to see an
example of these minimum uncertainty
states check out our video on the wave
functions of coherent states
and as always if you like the video
please subscribe